أنا أحب القفز مع أسماك قرش الحوت ،
ولكن قد يكون الأمر مخيفًا
لأنهم أكبر سمكة في البحر
بحجم الحافلة
، ولأن مثل هذا المخلوق الضخم يأتي
إليك من اللون الأزرق الغامق ،
فإنه نوعًا ما يأخذك
لقد أتى براد نورمان ،
أحد المدافعين عن البيئة البحرية ، إلى نينغالو منذ أكثر من 25
عامًا لدراسة هذه
الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض التي تأرجحت مع
أسماك قرش الحوت في
آلاف المناسبات ، لكنني ما زلت أتلقى ضجة في
كل مرة أخرج فيها
أسماك قرش الحوت هي عملاق لطيف هم
إعادة أكبر سمكة في البحر
ولكنها في الواقع ليست خطرة ، فهي
تتغذى على كائنات صغيرة جدًا
تتعرض أسماك قرش الحوت للخطر بسبب النشاط البشري
حيث يقدر أن عدد السكان قد
انخفض بأكثر من 50 في المائة في الـ
75 عامًا الماضية
وفقًا للاتحاد الدولي  من أجل
الحفاظ على الطبيعة ،
يقول نورمان إن أكبر التهديدات هي
تدمير موائل الصيد
وتغير المناخ يمكن أن يكون لتغير المناخ
تأثير كبير
على فريسة أسماك قرش الحوت يمكن أن يغير
درجات حرارة الماء
تيارات متغيرة ويمكن أن تغير
المناطق التي قد تتحرك أسماك قرش الحوت عادةً
لإطعام
[موسيقى
] المياه الفيروزية في هذه
المحمية الطبيعية بغرب أستراليا
حيث وقع نورمان لأول مرة في حب
جزيرة عش الصخور في المحيط التي لها تاريخ طويل في
حياتي.  اعتدت المجيء إلى هنا
في عطلاتنا المدرسية وكان هنا أن
أسبح وأغطس
في هذه البيئة الجميلة وهذا
شجعني حقًا
على الرغبة في السير في طريق كوني
عالم أحياء بحرية
، جعل نورمان الوعي العام مفتاحًا
لأبحاثه التي
تساعد  عثرت على برنامج تعريف بالصور
لأسماك قرش الحوت
يرسم خرائط مناطقها الساخنة والهجرات العالمية
مع عمليات إرسال من أكثر من 10000 شخص
في أكثر من 50 دولة
، بدأنا في اكتشاف المناطق ذات
الأهمية الحاسمة لأسماك قرش الحوت
حيث
يسافرون إليها  جوانب مهمة من
أسماك قرش الحوت في حياتها مغطاة
بنمط جميل من الخطوط والبقع
ولكن كيف نقارن نمطًا واحدًا من
البقع مقابل  آخر
لذلك قمنا بتكييف خوارزمية يستخدمها علماء ناسا
في تلسكوب هابل الفضائي لرسم خريطة
للنجوم في سماء الليل ،
قمنا بتعيين نمط البقع على
جلد سمكة قرش الحوت ، ثم نقوم
بمسح التعرف على بصمات الأصابع تلك
الصورة مقابل
آلاف الصور الأخرى و  إذا كانت
مطابقة ، فهي نفس سمكة القرش ،
فإن الكتاب البري لأسماك قرش الحوت عبارة عن
قاعدة بيانات على الإنترنت
تشجع أفراد الجمهور على
أن يكونوا علماء مواطنين
إذا تمكنوا من رؤية سمكة قرش الحوت
وكانوا يسبحون مع أحدهم لالتقاط صورة
لمنطقة الهوية الخاصة  التي هي
وراء الخياشيم ،
أرسلها إلى الكتاب البري جيدًا ، حيث
نجد المزيد عن هذه
الحيوانات ، ستساعدنا في وضع أنظمة
وطرق لحمايتها على المدى
الطويل ،
وهذا النوع من بيانات التعهيد الجماعي أمر حيوي
للحفاظ على أسماك قرش الحوت ،
كما يقول نورمان و  من خلال
السياحة البيئية المسؤولة في أماكن مثل
ningaloo ، يمكن أن تقدم للجمهور طرقًا جديدة
لمساعدة هؤلاء العمالقة اللطفاء على مدى
السنوات القليلة
الماضية في عدد مرات المشاهدة
يتزايد في كل وقت
من المهم جدًا أن يساعد أفراد من
الجمهور في مشروعنا من
خلال التقاط صورة ومساعدتنا
في بحثنا ،
يمكننا جميعًا العمل معًا لإنقاذ هذا
النوع